you
and
[Music]
[Applause]
we're a live combat sort of promotion we
have multiple events all over the world
we have a pretty small staff and it's
very mobile staff we have to travel
everywhere pretty much everything we do
requires that we're in a venue in a
hotel in a conference center we produce
pay-per-view events and then everything
kind of spiders out from that a lot of
it the interest based media and content
for the fans
production-wise on any given week we
could be creating four five post
produced shows along with promo videos
for upcoming fights acerra
is the back end of our digital asset
management system so even internally
between our LA and Las Vegas offices so
guys no video back and forth gigabytes
of video back and forth all the time we
drop a sixty foot office trailer and do
a lot of our operations on-site because
we have so much content that rolls into
the broadcast we have a team on the
ground that actually goes behind the
scenes they're pulling content in we
have people editing it and we're pushing
it out in a matter of hours the way we
move video around in relation to our
live event is through a relatively new
tapeless workflow over the last year we
have completely changed our workflow to
espera delivery one of the things that
espera has allowed us to do is take a
very small team of people and create a
tremendous amount of content and
distribute it over a wide variety of
partners our editors are using that
system but also our distribution folks
are using that same system to pop video
in and out all the time mostly outs we
distribute massive quantities of video
every day we used to deliver 90% of our
content on tape just a year and a half
ago now it's completely reversed we
deliver about 95% of our content by
espera we've been able to get a lot of
our partners to come over to the digital
realm as well once they saw the the
benefit of it they were soon telling us
never to
safe anymore right now we currently have
over 200 espero clients Matt's push
clients pull clients most folks don't
even know the despair is back there
behind our asset management system or
behind our web distribution system it's
not something that we have to have our
creative minds spend time on worrying
about what kind of delivery affair is
putting there in the background it's
reliable it's easy you know it's a
single button solution we could not live
two days without aspera it would just it
would kill us it would totally kill it
it would totally hang come so a spare is
vitally important to my workflow and my
distribution team because I have a core
very small core set of people just
allowed to push out exponentially more
content to different partners
efficiently quickly and nimbly and be
more responsive which i think is crucial
to promoting our court and growing our
brands there's no way we could have done
this earlier in our life distribute this
kind of material as broadly as we do we
just couldn't have done it without the
ability to deliver video as quickly as
asparagus
[Music]